what's up man what do you got for me
tonight
now that was just a question because um
so my buddy he's always like yo let's go
out let's go out and i'm always like you
know i'm
kind of just wanna i feel guilty
sometimes when i go out and kind of
socialize or trying to meet women
because i'm like well i'm not really
where i want to be
right now but then i also kind of now
that i turn 30 i'm like well when he
says go out like like what's he talking
about going to a nightclub like
bars breweries and stuff like ted to
meet girls and stuff which i mean
honestly like going out with him i've
met
more women that i definitely have in the
past what is what is what does your
friend do like what is the uh business
owner is the employee like what does he
do from no he um he's got like a
warehouse trap
okay and he's really just going out to
chase tail
pretty much he
we both broke up with our girls about
the same time so he's kind of trying to
get the ball rolling with that too okay
one more like what he's not your
dog making that noise yeah this my bad
a little diesel right here
all right so okay so you're going out
and
you're asking should i go out with this
dude to these clubs in these uh right
yeah because um like i said i where are
you on a scale of one to ten with 10
being the best version and one being the
worst version um i'd say i'm a
let's say like a five six okay so have
you read my book
yeah i read it a few times already i've
read a few of the books that you've
mentioned on your channel so yeah so i
talked about that in the book right i
mean like yeah you can go and talk to
the ladies you know you can chase some
tail if you want but you're going to be
doing a lot of work like the roi is
going to be low
right your your energy your time your
investment is far better spent on
yourself leveling yourself up
you know to get yourself to a point
where you're a 7 or 8 out of 10 because
then you're going to have a better
experience than where you are right now
okay you're just going to spend time and
money at what you know chasing women
that don't have genuine desire for you
right yeah and honestly um
i read your book as i was
broke up with my previous relationship
and like you said all those red flags i
moved in with this chick too and
that's kind of where it kind of derailed
me because i was on a pretty good course
before that i was already kind of
starting my own business um kind of
teaching myself instead of going back to
school so everything was good but then
like 2020 happened to where i had to
kind of
go back into my family's business and
kind of start doing um kind of i guess
how do i say go back to the drawing
board
yeah
okay
spend the time in yourself is basically
what i'm saying you know okay you're 30
you said
yes yeah so spend the time on yourself
you know double down on what this new
version of you looks like take a look at
your last relationship everything that
went sideways from it what you learned
from that i mean i'm not saying don't
talk to women i'm not saying don't you
know have some fun do it
but just understand that
your time is far better spent on
yourself like you got to where you're at
right now you can only take yourself as
far as the experiences and the lessons
that you've learned right
so what you know today is far more than
what you've known before like one of the
things that i always tell guys is you
know the first step is you got to unplug
from
your own first like the lies
that you tell yourself and then you
gotta the next step is you have to
unplug from the lies everybody else
tells you from all that now
that now that you've started to go
through that process that's great
now what kind of results are you going
to start to pull into your life so that
you can have better experiences
everywhere
i'm not just talking about women talking
about everywhere
okay right like that's what the
unplugged do
if i kind of ask one last question that
kind of um goes with this one too is
how do you work on not not really
getting your frame back but
like starting to build a new frame that
you kind of
want moving forward instead of being
known for who you were before but then
kind of
move on to where what you want to be i'm
not sure i understand the question about
frame maybe you can rephrase it for me
so um
so when when like friends
approach me or talk to me they still
kind of have that mentality of who i was
back then so i'm sometimes i'm not that
guy anymore
right
i'm not like like one of the things that
that will end up happening as you become
better like if your friends continue
doing this and you're doing this
okay like you're improving your lives
friends and even family you know they're
gonna say
i don't like this new version of you
corona
i like the old guy better
right okay well the reason why i got up
here and my life improved is because i
stopped doing a lot of dumb and i
started adopting new and better
behaviors so i don't really care whether
or not you like me or not like it's
gonna happen you know i'll tell you guys
right now you and anybody else watching
this as you improve yourself as your
life gets better it's like crabs in a
bucket right they always try to pull you
back down
they don't want you to get better i like
the old guy better
yeah that's kind of what what i'm
balancing with is is like
like guilt because i come from a very
cultural family so
when you don't when you kind of deviate
from that and you kind of start doing
things a little different they kind of
question so so let's talk about guilt
because guilt is a negative emotion
that's towards yourself
resentment's towards somebody else these
are the two most negative emotions you
can have as a human being you can go
back and look at brian trace's very very
early from like 30 40 years ago we
talked about this sort of stuff a lot
all you have to do is let it go
okay
it doesn't matter like why do you feel
guilty over chasing excellence right
that's dumb
yeah like should i feel guilty for
having a mclaren in my garage that's
dumb
you know i've had people tell me like oh
you know why don't you why don't you
sell the car and like feed some hungry
people well i happened to feed engineers
and experts that designed and built this
thing so that the world can be
entertained by formula one racing okay
how about that
right there's probably you know some
guys on that team that might have
designed a rocket at the spacex team
that are sending satellites up so that
we can have
internet around the world you know
starlink sort of thing
so
i don't
i don't fall for the guilt i don't fall
for for any of that stuff and the sooner
that you can let go of that and
walk away from it and not let it hold
you back because it's an anchor you know
i've talked about anchors and sales
you've watched me for a while obviously
sales fill up you know they pull you to
the next passage anchors hold you back
you got to cut back like guilt you
know you shouldn't be phil you know
feeling guilt over chasing excellence
you shouldn't be feeling guilt over
about you know becoming better while
everybody else doesn't want to do
anything any different right
yeah that's um
that's like one of those things too
because i wanted to do my own thing
wanted to move out and they're like well
i mean you know being here with families
you know family you don't gotta you
don't gotta pay but it's like at the
same time it's like i'm i'm almost
i'm almost 30 i got to start kind of
bending yeah you got to get your
together man right you want to be
spoiled for choice of women have a
better life yeah you can't be living at
your parents house at 30. exactly
all right level up thank you appreciate
it all right buddy
um let's go back to the private chat
here
jenna is wearing a face mask and she has
to wash it off
doesn't want to be public all right
jenna
i'm gonna i'm gonna give you a couple
minutes
you